a death row inmate in Texas whose cases
gained national attention could learn
today whether the US Supreme Court will
hear his case Rodney Reed is his name
he's scheduled to be executed in just
five days for the rape and murder of 19
year-old Stacey Stites this happened
back in 1996 his request for review has
huge online support Omar Villafranca is
outside the Supreme Court with more on
this story he caught up with Reed's
family last night
Omar what they tell you well Gail Reed's
family wants the Supreme Court to
intervene there was a small crowd that
gathered here last night praying that
the court would hear their case and in
fact nearly 3 million people have signed
a petition asking Texas governor Greg
Abbott to halt the execution and
consider the new evidence and we're
going to stand on the truth until my
brother is Roger Creed and about 3 dozen
other people prayed on the steps of the
highest court in the land for a legal
Hail Mary for his brother Rodney I
prayed that it wouldn't have to go this
far but there's no extent that I will
not go through to see the justices head
for my brother because it's innocent
Rodney Reed is scheduled to die by
lethal injection next week unless the
supreme court agrees to take up his case
which according to Reed's attorney Jane
poacher would postpone his execution the
next steps would be a stay in his
execution and then the case would be
sent back to the state court for further
litigation Reed was convicted in 1998 of
killing 19 year-old Stacey stipes in
Bastrop Texas his DNA was found in
Stites body Reed says he was having an
affair with her he talked to dr. Phil
McGraw last month did you murder Stacey
Stites lower courts have denied Reed's
appeal but celebrities and even a
bipartisan group of Texas lawmakers have
asked governor Greg Abbott to halt his
execution and consider new evidence
including a new potential suspect one
witness actually came forward to say
that Jimmie confessed to him to having
killed Stacey Stites Jimmie Finnell was
a cop and Stites fiance he served time
in prison for an unrelated kidnapping
unwanted sexual contact his attorney Bob
Phillip says Finnell did not murder
Stites and says Reid is no saint because
he has been accused of rape before why
is nobody in the ashtag me to world that
we live in talking about these women
Reid did face a series of sexual assault
allegations but was acquitted in the
only case prosecuted
I don't think Rodney Reed killed my
cousin Heather sobs its tights cousin
and believes Finnell killed her
what part of this weighs on you the most
I want justice for Stacey and in order
to do that we have to do justice for
Rodney Reed now the legal waiting game
begins the court could decide to hear
Reid's case today or they could wait a
few days keep in mind he's scheduled to
be executed on Wednesday but still they
could make their decision just minutes
before he's scheduled to be put to death
yep Anthony all right Omar thank you